okay so as you probably guessed this is
a talk about cryptography I warn you
upfront it's quite theory heavy not a
great deal of PHP code and I am aware it
is 4:00 p.m. on Friday so please try and
stay in the room so some introduction
what what is it that we talk about when
we talk about cryptography so modern
cryptography covers sort of three quite
important areas the first one is
probably one everyone thinks of first is
message privacy that means ensuring that
any communications between two parties
can only be read by the intended
recipient and the sender another sort of
facets to to modern cryptography is be
able to verify a message that's ensuring
that a message that you've received is
it's the message that was actually sent
by the person that sent it and it's not
been tampered with between you and the
sender and and will the final sort of
main areas that it deals with is
identity verification so ensuring that
the message that you've received did
actually come from the person who claims
to have sent it and it's not a fake
message that you've received from
someone who's playing a joke on you so
that's a sort of third set area now if
you've been to any other talks
maybe this conference or another one on
application security you better see it's
talk this I think this is from last year
or two years ago looks a bit like this
cryptography is really quite a hard
thing to to get right especially if you
start diving into diet design your own
algorithms and things like that and so
the main purpose of this talk is to take
a brief journey through the evolution of
cryptography right from the very very
beginning all the way up to the
algorithms that we use in today and try
and give you a bit of an appreciation of
quite why it's so hard and and why it's
important to get it right so I'm gonna
start with some historic ciphers which
actually don't pen and paper if you if
you want to and then I'm gonna move on
some
workings of of things IAS and/or say
crypto systems which are in use today
so first on to the historic ciphers the
the first one we could take a look at
you probably all heard of this one this
is a shift it's probably about the
simplest cipher you could you could
think up and the basic idea is what you
take a message with some words and in
order to encrypt it you shift characters
in the message up or down the alphabet
by fixed amount that looks like this and
you can see we've got like an alphabet
at the top and then in order to apply
the Caesar shift transformation
encryption on on a message we sort of
shift each letter so now becomes a D and
then so on so forth it's not going to be
a very short talk if this was the
state-of-the-art modern cryptography so
so what what's actually wrong with this
cipher why why should you not use it
well turns out that for forgiving
alphabet there's a very very small
number of possible keys obviously they
only got 26 letters in the English
alphabet and that gives you 25 possible
different shifts that you can use to
encode a message using the Caesar shift
obviously if user 26 won it just encode
it back to itself which is very useful
either even if you were to use like
binary ASCII and applies either shift
you're still only looking at 255
different possible shifts that would
mean any anyone wanted to read a message
that you've sent that you've you've
encoded you can see the shift could
simply just run through right little
script try every different possible
shift and see which which one made a
message that makes sense and that'd be
really easy for them to quickly run
through and and decode your message this
is quite important to us because it
illustrates a really important aspect of
a strong cipher it's the fact that it's
got to have a large number of possible
keys that's preventing any attacker from
just iterating through them all to try
and decode your message so move on to
maybe a another straightforward cipher
so an evolution step up
it's a solution cipher unless this works
in a sort of similar way but instead of
just moving that up we which randomly
shuffle them around so you just swap the
letter a letter in your your plaintext
for a letter for a different random
letter okay and this looks a bit like
this so this this one I've sort of
picked a an encoding which changes a
towards ed a b2 as n c2 q etc and you do
that's the entire alphabet how does it
hold up this one is actually
significantly better for the Caesar
shift ours our algorithm using just
English for your institution and just
letters there are four hundred and three
septillion 291 sextillion 461
quintillion 126 quadrillion 605 trillion
635 million 584 million possible
different keys it's quite big number so
with such a large large number of keys
you'd think that this is a really really
quite strong cipher right why don't we
why aren't we using a substitution
cipher to store people's bank details
well turns out the weakness of the
substitution cipher doesn't actually
come from from the low number of keys
it's security is equivalent to about an
eighty eight bit key so that's obviously
not as strong as from the modern ciphers
that use 128 or 256 bits but it's still
pretty strong and it's only sort of just
within our computational capabilities to
to brute force a key of that size um
instead the substitution cipher false
foul of probably the greatest nemesis of
cryptographic algorithms which is
statistics okay due to the simplicity of
the cipher it fails to hide any
underlying patterns in the in the data
that you've encrypted with it which
means that if you want to recover the
original plaintext if you've got a
message that someone's sent and you want
to read it you need to just look for the
patterns
if the patterns English text this is a
graph of all the various letter
frequencies in in the English language
so what you can do is you can you can
count up all the letters in you know
ciphertext that you've you've
intercepted and you can plot them on the
graph like this and then you can sort of
take a bit of a guess and say well the
lesser than occurs most commonly that's
probably the letter e okay cuz that's
the most common letter in in the English
language and once you've done that you
can you can guess that maybe fuel this
as a peak it sort of like around s and T
and some of the vowels hey you know you
can start to decipher bits and once
you've got little bits you can maybe
guess at words and say well looks like
left the word D which is one of the most
common words that gives you call more
letters you can start decoding it and
bit by bit you can sort of piece
together the full text of the message
takes a little bit of work but you can
automate it with a with a script quite
easily and you can decode this on paper
even so it's not really very strong so
we want to obviously the substitution
cipher was quite an old cipher and
Durin's all right the 1500 1600 s people
sought to to improve upon this was a
they sort of realized this wasn't hiding
the patterns quite so well and they came
up with this cipher called the Vigenere
cipher now this is one of a group of
ciphers known as polyalphabetic ciphers
if these are so called this because
instead of just using one possible
encoding for each each letter in your
your plaintext it uses several different
encodings that helps it better disguise
some of the underlying patterns in the
in the plaintext how this works for the
for this cipher is in order to to encode
a message you need to first of all pick
a key and this simple example here I've
picked the key T probably not a good
idea to use that as your your actual key
but it works quite nicely here for
example and and what we do is using the
the latter's here we set a to be equal
to the first letter of the key and we
get to see the shift for that we do the
same for E and the same for Y and then
we've got several different shifts that
we use one after the other that looks a
little bit like this so we've got a
message that we want to hide that's
pretty pretty secret message you
probably don't want people people
knowing that you're about to blow some
up you take the key and you encode the
first letter of your message using the
first Caesar shift represented by the K
letter the second one with e next one y
once you an out letters in your key you
repeat it and it looked about at that so
we we continue use it reusing this key
and we get out the ciphertext at the
bottom so anyone want to guess is this
cipher secure nope absolutely not
now it did take a while longer to break
it and it was credited to Charles
Babbage who no well-known historic
figure however it wasn't until 1985 that
this was actually recognized because it
was he did it and the British government
kind of kept it a bit secret because
they didn't anyone to know they'd broken
it
so until then someone else Frederick
gazecki had been credited with the
discovery he discovered it a bit later
and it's him that the techniques
actually named after unlike the simple
substitution cipher you can't actually
use frequency analysis if you've got a
ciphertext encode over this and if you
were to do frequency Alice's you'd
probably see something with a fairly
flat graph so all the letters to provide
the keys long enough you'll find that
that is frequency is a fairly similar to
each other and there's nothing that you
can sort of pick out fairly easily
however despite the fact you can't do
frequency analysis because the motor
pool encodings what you can do is you
can start looking for repeated sequences
of letters in the ciphertext now what
these repeated sequences sort of tell
you is possibly that's where the key has
is repeated in the in the cipher text
and so you can count the distance
between these repetitions
and you sort of noticed that that's
corresponding to the same word being
encoded and being been 12 that's the
part so this suggests that learned that
key is a multiple 12 well sorry 12 is a
multiple of that aquiline so the key
word that possibly been used to encode
this text could be 2 3 4 6 or even 12
characters long and then that actually
helped us to narrow down what this the
the key that was used to encode it might
be so what you can then do is I mean I
am cheating because I know how long the
kids I can take a guess that maybe the
keys three letters long and I split the
message into three groups taking the
first letter the fourth letter etc into
the first group the second letter fifth
letter etc into the second group and the
third letter and so on into the third
group you can then perform frequency
analysis on those those subgroups and it
should produce a graph that looks
similar to the long a few slides back
once you've done that you can sort of
take take the graph that you're looking
at try and line up the largest letter
with E and then that sort of helps you
to to work out what the the key word is
about that position wouldn't you've
actually done that
you better recover the key and decode
the message okay now um when I first get
this talk I I put together this little
cypher challenge a little bit more
difficult in the Vigenere cipher but
very very similar process so if anybody
fancies having to go up breaking one of
these themselves there's a link that
I've got it at the end of the talk so
I'll put it back up if you don't don't
manage to copy it down right now move on
to a different cypher this one probably
everyone in the room I would hope has
heard of enigma it 100 years after the
venire cipher that went by before the
the enigma cipher came around what will
suit to saw several attempts to
mechanize cryptography so move it from
our rooms that you could perform on pen
and paper to actually using machines to
perform cryptographic operations
obviously the most famous attempt was
the Germans Enigma
although during the war all the major
powers the Americans and the British
we're all using machines that worked in
a fairly similar way to encode their
attacks I mean the Americans and their
the British one was a little bit more
secure than nigma but same same sort of
underlying principles so an emu machined
not to be like this made up of four
parts a keyboard which was for typing
your message in have a typist to type in
a set of rotors on the back these actor
each of these acted as their own
substitution cipher there were commonly
three rotors in a machine but some of
the machines featured up to as many as
eight of these rotors that could be
interchanged the military machines but
the German used had five different
rotors which they could use in any any
combination so they could use like Lotus
1-2-3 on day and three four five the
next day and later on throughout the war
they expanded this to two a second with
the total of eight rotors which would
provide a little bit more security and
the final component this at the front
here was a plug board now this switched
around pairs of letters with with wires
and you could use up to 13 different
swaps but only usually about ten were
used this actually was one of the
features that oops was gave the Machine
quite a lot of security was the ability
to flip these letters that's quite a lot
of security came from so this is sort of
how it looks like inside
it's a electrical machine and so when a
typist presses a key on the front of any
more machine an electric current
completes the circuit which goes through
the plugboard
through each one of the rotors and get
sort of like mangled rook then the back
of machine there's a reflector which is
literally just a little wires that
reconnect the circuit back through each
of the three rotors back through the
plug board and finally it illuminates a
lamp
on the on the top of the top of the
machine then the radio operator would
send that letter and then all the rotors
would move around and when you press it
the next time it took a different path
through the machine and came up with a
different letter
obviously it stepped the first rotor one
at a time and once it gone all the way
around then that stepped over the next
one once the light had gone all the way
around it set the next one and so on and
so forth
that meant that each letter could be
encoded in a vast different variety of
different ways each time you use the
same letter by changing the mappings
this way it meant that the mapping of
the plaintext and ciphertext was
constantly changing and it makes you
really what to do any sort of like
frequency analysis or informal letters
and and sort of had the the the
cryptanalysis at Bletchley Park stumped
for quite a while on on how to actually
analyze these these messages
obviously the Enigma is quite famous but
one of the things it's famous for that
is for having been broken a team of
British cryptographers at Bletchley Park
led by Alan shearing it was also quite a
famous guy I've heard so designed
machines to help them break the
mechanical ciphers the breakthrough said
that the team made weren't particularly
based on weaknesses in the cipher and
the diagram itself but mostly on certain
operational errors made by the Germans
so examples of those errors included
choosing bad keys like AAA as a sort of
initial setting for the rotors this made
it fairly trivial to decode and and
having predictable message structures so
for example the first message most of
the German military units would send in
the morning would be a weather report
which would contain the German word for
weather what up and this was a the
weakness while the weaknesses that the
device designed by Alan Turing sort of
seized upon and it sort of looked for
the word wetter in in the
to text and then sort of like stepped
through all the possible different
combinations of rotors and and tool
board settings to try and find this and
they had full like rooms full of these
machines that aren't sharing and his
team designed look whenever they got a
message in first thing in the morning
one of machine operators rush in put the
missed message into the machine it were
away for a couple hours it find out the
key and once the Germans only changed
the keys once a day once the tram the
key for the day they could decrypt all
the messages that the Germans were
sending for that day and obviously that
did actually give the British and their
allies quite a big advance in the walk
was they knew exactly what the Germans
were up to
so obviously this break was quite a big
thing so we're gonna leave the historic
ciphers there now we've gone sort of
through all the way up to sort of the
beginning of the last century with it
halfway through with those machines and
we're gonna take a look at some of the
algorithms that are actually useful to
us today for for storing data securely
modern-day cryptography beginning can be
broken down into several different
problems that we need to be able to
solve to communicate securely the first
from those is its confidentiality we
need to ensure that people other than
the intended recipient can't read our
messages there's a wide variety of
different algorithms which people are
built for doing this but the probably
one you want to be using at these at the
moment is a yes advanced encryption
standard most of these algorithms are
symmetric that is they use the same key
for both encryption and decryption
there's there's two main classes within
that stream ciphers which work on
continuous streams of data and block
ciphers which break the messenger from
separate blocks and encrypt each
separately and we're showing example of
each in a few minutes
another thing that we need to solve is
if key exchange obviously if if want to
communicate with you securely we both
need to have a key that we can we can
use
encrypt messages so one of the ways that
we we do this is with asymmetric ciphers
now these ciphers that use a different
key for encrypting as they do for
decrypting and then we can sort of use
this you can give me the the encryption
key fairly safely I can use that to
encrypt a message to you but I can't
subsequently decrypt any messages there
in critical that key only you can with
the the other part of that key so that's
quite an important important thing that
we can do another thing that we can do
is verify the identity of a sender again
it works in a similar way to key
exchange you can sign a message using a
a private key that you keep with keep
secret and you can publish a public key
and you can say this is this is my
public key and anyone when they receive
a message from you can use that public
key to verify that it was signed with
your private key it's known as a message
signature and again go into detail this
later on this section another another
thing we need to do is authenticate a
message make sure that it hasn't been
tampered with
for this we use cryptographic hash
functions generally such as sha-256 so
when you can receive a message you can
compute the message hash and compare it
to one that's maybe been sent along with
a message and and signed with the the
private key of sender if it doesn't
match you can reject the message and say
someone's messed with this tampered with
it send it me again or whatever
obviously you need to combine the hash
with a secret key of some form otherwise
if someone tampered with it they could
just recompute the hash and a final
thing that people don't maybe realize is
a part of modern cryptography is the
ability to generate random numbers so a
large number of secure protocols rely on
being able to generate random numbers
that are actually random one example is
with using a public key cryptography
system you might generate a random key
to you to the symmetric cipher and
encrypt that with the with the public
and private keys and send the whole lot
along now if someone can predict the
number that came out your on your number
generator they can guess
that key was and they can just forget
about trying to break the algorithm they
can just decree the message so be able
to generate secure on your numbers it's
really important
okay so symmetric ciphers as I sort of
previously mentioned there's two classes
of symmetric cipher
there's block and stream ciphers all of
these algorithms are really only useful
for dealing with message confidentiality
there's no no symmetric algorithms you
can really use for key exchange the
moment and it doesn't really solve that
problem so I'm gonna start by looking at
stream ciphers how a stream cipher works
is it produces a constant stream of some
pseudo random output bytes and you use
the secret key that you you're using to
encrypt the message with as a sort of a
C's to this generator the produced bytes
from the generator then exhort with your
plaintext to produce the cipher text and
then you can send that along and the
person on the other end can produce the
same random pseudo-random stream of
bytes and use that exhort with the
plaintext over the cipher text to
recover the plaintext it's actually
fairly similar to how enigma works in a
way it's sort of stream ciphers sort of
evolved from the Enigma machine
there are several stream ciphers that we
currently use today probably the most
well-known is rc4 which is used in WEP
and an SSL but I've chosen a slightly
different one which is called a 5/1 now
you've probably ever heard of this
algorithm but I can almost guarantee
that every single want to do in this
room is using it because it's used to
protect voice and SMS data in mobile
phones this algorithm has actually been
broken it's it's no longer considered
secure it would state the art a few
decades ago and now it's it's quite not
but it's an interesting one to look at
as a stream cipher example how it sort
of works
like this diagram here so the it's got a
big state machine in the middle and it
consists of three registers this with
each with each of a different size and
what it does is each time you want a a
new bit out of your new random number
generator it takes the the top bit out
of each of these registers XOR them
together and that's the the output bit
that's produced once it's done map each
of these registers is shifted to the
left and depending on this byte here so
it's got these what what's called
clocking bits and so it compares each
from the the bits in the register and
says okay we'll take the majority so if
they're all zeros the majority 0 and any
that match that majority bit are clocked
and in that don't match it left so if
you've got sort of say 1 0 1 the the
majority bit there is one so any
registers that match that the first and
the third get clocked and move to the
left one in order to generate a new by
onto the back here it takes the bits
that are colored in blue X awesome
together and and produces a a new bit on
the end so take a look at that in more
detail how it actually works and it
clocks this is the most register from
the previous diagram you can sort of see
it's got some sort of numbers in there
and we clock it once and everything
shifts left X all these bits and put it
back on the end next cycle we do the
same thing XOR it put it back on the end
and this generates a a really long
sequence of different bytes and
obviously got three of these so you get
quite a large sequence of random data
coming out of it ok now stream ciphers
are quite useful but they do have a few
things that you need to keep in mind
when you're using them the first one is
that keys must not be reused because of
the way that it can by
the output of the cipher using XOR it
will always produce the same output
bytes so if you produce if you encrypt
two different messages with the same key
somebody can actually use those two
messages to start recovering parts of
your output stream and therefore they
can actually decrypt your your messages
to guard against this a lot of stream
ciphers include what's known as the
initialization vector or IV which is
combined in some way with the with the
secret key and then you sort of send
that ID along with your message as part
of it and then someone using the same
algorithm to combine that key with your
IV and then that make sure you're always
using a different key for each message
WP EP is actually vulnerable because of
this although they use an IV in the
initialization of the rc4 algorithm the
IV that they picked was too small which
means that over some time if you're
sending lots of Wi-Fi packets back and
forth you'll eventually repeat not just
the secret key but the the IVs will
repeat that means at once once someone
detects two messages using the same IV
they can use those messages to decode
the output stream and at that point they
can they can sort of recover the key for
the network and connect your Wi-Fi
network and sniff your traffic and
things which is sort of why we've sort
of phased out WP in in Wi-Fi these days
it's kind of easy for an attacker to
modify a message so let's say you're
downloading a HTML page from website and
you're encoding it with a stream cipher
anyone who can suggest that maybe
there's a JavaScript file in the header
of that can actually compute a an XOR
with what they think might be in the
message and what they really want in the
message and it's all that into the
cipher text and that will actually
replace it in the cipher text and it'll
decode to what they want it to rather
than what was sent this means that when
you're actually using the stream cipher
you need to make sure you've got some
sort of message authentication to
prevent this tampering such as a message
hash
it's also it's not so much a security
concern of a practical one most stream
ciphers require that you run them all
the way through to decrypt a message and
you can't sort of arbitrarily seep into
a stream cipher some of them have been
designed to allow this but most do not
this means if you're say you've
encrypted a huge 50 gig database backup
using a stream cipher and you need to
recover one table worth of data from
that backup and you know that it's 20
gig away in you're still going to have
to decrypt the first 20 gig to get to
that table data you can't just sort of
seek into it and decrypt just the bit
you need to be aware of next thing we
look at is the box either the key
difference between a a block and a
stream cipher is that where's the stream
cipher produces bases pseudo-random
stream where you can use to encrypt a
block cipher actually works on a block
of your plain text directly and applies
various different mathematical
transformations to it now the the size
of block works differently depending on
the algorithm but it's usually much
shorter than any message you might want
to send a s for example uses 128-bit
blocks older ciphers tend to use 64 bits
so that's that's obviously a lot shorter
than any any message you're going to
want to send so you need to break up
your message into blocks and encrypt
each one separately and that's where the
name comes from a block cipher so
obviously the probably most famous one
you've heard of is a s and that's kind
of like they probably the one you'll be
using for a lot of your day today
encryption needs a s was a result of a
cryptography competition to find a
replacement for an all of an order
encryption standard the data encryption
standard and it was eventually won by a
slight variant of the rhein gel
algorithm now you might know if you've
been using the m crypt extension that
there are there is a different flavor
of AAS that's just called range L and if
you use the wrong constants with M crypt
you use that one instead it's not quite
what you want but ever got you though
fortunately it's been deprecated but if
anyone's still using it so much look out
for so how is works is it's got so you
start off for the message and you apply
the AES algorithm to it repeatedly for a
few cycles depending on the key length
is depending on how many how many actual
cycles you you run through of a s each
round of an a s consists of four
distinct phases which is substitute
bytes shift rows mixed columns and then
it adds a portion of the of the secret
key to data and then it repeats the loop
again so each one of those rounds is
applied every time you sort of loop
through looking a bit more detail the
substitute bites it works on a block
size of 128 bits and it's effectively
got a substitution cipher with a fixed
key now the the key had actually nosin
to try and avoid a number of different
algorithmic and cryptographic techniques
to provide defense against various
various techniques that we used against
the predecessor des so the bits and the
substitution table have been chosen
specifically and what happens basically
is it just takes the current bite in the
state looks up that bite in the
substitution table and replaces that
bite in your current block with the bite
on the substitution table next thing
that happens is each each row in your
and your sort of block is shifted using
a bit shift operation and then you
select rotate the first bite around to
the end
so sort of that diagram the third step
is better a complicated mathematical
operation but it effectively does a
multiplication over each column and it
does like to sort of like mix up the the
data in different way for the final ride
of the cipher this steps actually
skipped over so it doesn't doesn't occur
in the last round but it's every round
other than that and then finally it
takes a bite from your key and it solves
it with a byte in the block and then
produces the final output once you've
gone through all those steps a number of
times I think it's 14 rounds 420 a bit
key then you output a block of
ciphertext it's quite an efficient
algorithm it's in printing in hardware
and quite a lot processes these days so
it's it's very fast to compute and how
it works now obviously with the block
cipher you're going to want to encrypt
more than 128 bits at a time and so when
we use a block cipher a message is
longer than that we've got to split up
into blocks however there are quite a
lot of different ways in which you can
utilize a block cipher and these are
known as modes of operations so one mode
is known as the excellent cookbook it's
probably the one that you'd you'd sort
of think up first is you literally
encrypt a block of text and then the
next one and the next one and just
append them like that so you've got a
plaintext
you've got key you do your block cipher
encryption and you get output block you
do the next block next block and you
just spend them believe it or not this
is a really bad mode which you shouldn't
use although block cipher produces a
really random output and it's it's
really difficult to reverse that any
block any piece of plaintext that's the
same same 128 bits will come out as a
ciphertext that's exactly the same this
actually gives you the same problem so
that's with a substitution cipher where
someone can actually look at statistical
patterns in your data obviously it's a
bit more difficult but
take a look at this penguin tux Linux
mascot and that's tux encrypted using a
s in ECB mode you can quite clearly see
that that tux is still there now if this
was an image that maybe you you wanted
not for people not together see have it
having it like that probably wouldn't be
your your desired result so you should
never really use ECB mode unless you
just want to make cool pop art images
like this that's that's a legitimate use
I guess so a bit of an improvement the
first sort of attempt to fix that sort
of problem was called cipher block
chaining how that sort of works is you
take an installation vector similar to
to a stream cipher and you feed that in
for your first block and your XL what
were your plaintext pass it through a
block cipher encryption and then you get
your cipher text for your next block you
pass that ciphertext back in XOR with
the plaintext and and pass it through
and you do that all the way along this
apps are sort of like a randomizer to
your your plaintext so even if you've
got two blocks that's same because this
and they start going the same they're
going to come out differently
it's obviously bit similar to a stream
cipher in the fact that you need an
initialization vector and you should not
reuse those but that sort of half solves
this the problems of the ECB another
another mode that's being used is called
CTR mode or counter mode this is quite a
cool mode in the fact that it turns a
block cipher into a stream cipher with a
few advantages so it completely
different from the previous two modes
that we've looked at as we no longer
directly encrypt our plaintext what we
do is we start off with a nonce on
initialization vector again and we have
a counter which we start 0 0 0 0 and we
encrypt that instead and explore it with
our plaintext
use the ciphertext and for that block
you increment the counter encrypt that X
all right you keep on going until you've
got enough bytes to encrypt your whole
message now due to the random nature of
the the output of a block cipher it
effectively turns it into a stream
cipher now obviously with CTR mode you
need to set the same precautions as with
a stream cipher such as not reusing the
IV and things and ensuring you've got a
[Music]
sort of a message authentication to to
make sure it's something tampered with
something else that this gives you that
stream cipher doesn't is you can
actually seek into your encrypted text
but if you want to get block 557 all you
do is take your nonce increment the
counter to 557 pass it to the block
cipher and you can decrypt into your
into your encrypted data you can decrypt
it and without having to decrypt
everything up to that point
another mode which which sort of helps
alleviate the issue that we had with
with CTR mode in the fact that it's a
stream cipher that authentication is
glorius counter mode what this does is
it combines the counter mode with an
authentication tag which helps verify
that message hasn't been tampered with
how that works is first of all you've
got here you've basically got the count
you've got the counter mode going on up
here as well but you also have a
separate part of your key which is off
data here which goes to a multiplication
function and then you start exploring it
with each your cipher text bytes and you
sort of chain on lots of different
multiplications of your ciphertext and
then finally add on the length of your
your your cipher texts and data and that
produces you an authentication tag which
when the person who you send the message
to receives it they can verify that
authentication tag before decrypting the
message and make sure it hasn't been
tampered with how that works
so that sort of covered off a lot of the
symmetric ciphers all those ciphers
we've looked at so far including even
the historic ones use a single key for
both encrypting and decrypting that
leads to a really hollow solved problem
which is key distribution imagine for a
moment that you're an undercover agent
Alice is undercover and in deep in enemy
operations and needs to get a secret
message back to Bob HQ to to send
mission reports and and tell Bob what's
the the evil overlord is talk to and
they obviously need to do so without the
the agents of the enemy Mallory and Eve
eavesdropping and modifying the messages
this is where the asymmetric ciphers
actually comes in because they use
different keys for encryption and
decryption we don't need to sort of pre
share keys so I can just keep on the
encrypting message to you without having
to worry about keeping my key secure and
things like that and even if I send the
message out and it's intercepted and the
enemy capture it they won't be able to
search my room and find the key that I
used to encrypt it because it's a public
key that that can't decrypt it again so
looking at public key cryptography quite
good good we're thinking about this is
think about padlock so it's padlocked
okay now imagine that I I want to send a
message so in the back of the room or
they want to send on to me what I could
do is I could give the metal box
nice nice sturdy metal box and they
could write their message on a piece of
paper and I could give my padlock okay
and they could they could attach this
padlock to the box
locking it and they could pass them a
pass the box back from the back of the
room past all your people who who we
don't really trust back to me and none
of you unless you've got some bolt
cutters
brute force I can be have to undo that
padlock but as soon as it gets back to
me I've got the put the private key I'm
keeping over here I can lock it and I
can read the message that's kind of the
same same idea that that public key
cryptography you
well the first and oldest public key
system is its RSA despite the huge
amount of protein power improvements and
things like that we've made since its
invention it's it's still quite secure
algorithm it relies on a sort of
mathematical problem which is quite easy
to compute in one direction but is
really difficult to to reverse and how
it sort of so if you've just set this
mathematical problem it's really for to
reverse but if you happen to know a
secret that was used when constructing
the problem its release if you to
reverse again we have actually come up
with better public key RM since but only
by the third to the fact that they're
actually more efficient implementing
code and they use less CPU cycles to run
they're not actually much greater in the
level of security they provide it's just
you can use shorter keys with them so
the mathematical problem that RSA is
based on is exponential in modular
arithmetic so the idea is that you can
find three rather large numbers e here D
and a prime number N and such that when
you take e to take any number and raise
it to the power of E and then raise it
to the power of D it equal to itself
modulus de prime number n ok so it's
sort of cyclic now if you've got a
message that's been coded like this and
you only have e it is really really
difficult to figure out what D is
mathematically however if you already
know D you can actually reverse it so
you can make this number and any
publicly available and you can you
compose this mathematical problem to the
world safe in the knowledge that it's
really really hard for them to solve it
and so in order to actually use this for
crypto system what you can do is you've
got my my public key which is e n N
and you can take the message that you
want to send to me you can raise it to
the power of e take its modulus find my
prime number and and that becomes a
ciphertext you can send that to me say
from the knowledge that only the person
with D can do this multiplication here
and reverse the process and turn it back
into the plaintext and obviously a
slight issue with this scheme is that
the message and must be smaller than
this this modulus use so usually what
you'll do with RSA and similar public
key algorithms is that you'll generate a
random string that you use for a
symmetric cipher like a yes and then you
use RSA or the public key algorithm to
encrypt just the key part of the
symmetric cipher and then you'll send
the ciphertext and the symmetric cipher
the encrypted key to your intended
recipient they can then use their
private key to recover the random key
and then they can decrypt message
there's a two-stage process and and that
sort of solves the key distribution
problem another thing we need solve is
identification
I don't deep verification
so although Alice and Bob can send
messages to each other
securely without Eve being able to
eavesdrop and recover those messages how
can they protect from the mischievous
Mallory who likes to tamper with
messages and change them turns out you
can actually use a similar thing with
RSA if I take a message say hash of the
ciphertext that I'm sending to you and I
raise it to the power of my private key
D I can send that as a signature when
Bob back in the office receives that
message he can raise it to the power of
my public key and if it has been signed
using my private key it will return back
to the value of the hash he can then
hash the message check it matches and
then he knows that it was sent
by alice obviously if it doesn't match
then someone's gone wrong and he knows
that the message has been tampered with
or or didn't come from Alice in the
first place again in practice that that
message must be short so the signature
is usually a cryptographic hash on the
message my char two five six or similar
so I've covered a selection of all the
algorithms that are in use today that
solve quite a lot of the problems in
modern cryptography so this last five
minutes or so we're going to look at how
you'd actually go about implementing
cryptography in an applications you need
to do so the first bit of information
that if advice is don't I hope that
you've sort of got an idea from this
talk just how how many things you have
to sort of keep an eye on and how
difficult it is to actually do these
things securely so if you've got a need
to encrypt data don't try and do it
yourself as much as possible it's very
easy to introduce vulnerabilities into
applications through things like side
channels someone measuring how even if
you take a s which is a secure algorithm
and implement it if you don't take care
of things like how long it takes to
encrypt the data someone might be able
to retrieve information about your key
or your plain text just by measuring how
long it actually takes to encrypt
messages and things like that so the
best bit of advice is use an existing
implementation okay everything I've gone
over today is battle tested and and
hardened and it's been pored over by
cryptographers for at least a decade and
there are well-known well tested well
used implementations out there use one
of those okay mostly its distros for
example allow you to encrypt hard drive
partitions that's a good starting point
all the major web servers have support
for TLS use SSL for your connections
between between servers don't try and
manually implement in your application
some sort of encrypting send it over
HTTP decrypt on the other side just use
HTTP well-tested
it's it's going to work okay
another option
if you've got to to remote data centers
you could use a VPN between the two or
maybe an SSH tunnel again all of these
protocols and algorithms have been well
tested there's lots of people going over
the source code all the time they're
patching there's security
vulnerabilities and things like that
you're benefiting from the knowledge of
people who who do this all the time okay
if one of those situations doesn't fit
your use case if you do actually need to
influence some cryptography bring in an
expert
okay bring in someone to audit your code
and make sure you've not made any
mistakes it's it's not a cryptography
isn't a skill that most developers are
like really tip-top on so although you
can probably implement it bring someone
in an expert and outside consultancy and
getting to just make sure you've done it
right
it might seem expensive to bring someone
in to do that
but it's nothing to patch the costs if
you become like if you get hacked and
you become an X like actually Addison or
so neither it sort of forget all that
data spewed all over the Internet
especially with the the GDP are comin in
now that's that can be quite costly if
if you make a mistake with this stuff
so bring an expert it'll save you money
and worry in the long run obviously
there's a PHP conference so what you
need to watch Eve what should you do if
you actually need to encrypt and decrypt
stuff in PHP there's a lot libraries out
there I've reviewed a lot of them
there's quite a few that default to
using pop-up penguin mode and insecure
other options and if you would just
download it with composure and be like
yep that's the library I'll use that
you'll end up with a few problems like
people being out to view your images or
pop-up versions of them so top my list
of recommendations is a library that
Scott Hazuki has written which is
highlight how it's a wrapper around lib
sodium which is a library that's been
written by cryptographers to limit the
amount of choices that developers
you've got what implementation of things
and that's a secure implementation and
that's the sort of the design goal of
zip sodium and and highlight just
provides a high level in place for that
which is really straightforward it looks
a little like this that would be how you
would encrypt something using highlight
the wrapper around lips sodium it's that
easy and that will be secure okay so if
you need to do something that's your
best option
lip sodium is in PHP 7.2 you can install
the extension tackle for versions before
7.2 if you're in an environment where
you can't install it
Scott's also written a polyfill in PHP
which you can actually include and it's
got all the same algorithms written in
PHP so you've got a very good range of
options now if you if you want to use
that if for some reason you you can't
use lip sodium for whatever reason maybe
you need a compatible to the legacy
system or something that diffuse PHP
encryption is another good library
that's implemented in PHP it look it
uses a lot more the the somebody older
style algorithms a yes and an RSA for
its cryptography and it tries to import
those in a secure way and it will fall
back to slight open SSL if you've got it
installed and things like that still
still be quite performant so that's
another option it's got a fairly similar
api to highlight so it's pretty much
diffuse encrypt and if you decrypt so
it's easy to get right so that's pretty
much the end of close to the end of the
talk so I've got a few links now for
anybody who's interested in finding out
more there's there's a wealth of really
interesting stuff on cryptography one of
the best ones if you're interested in
their historic side of the talk is Simon
sings the code book he's got a few the
ones I went over and a few other ones
and there's also some really interesting
case studies on what happened when
cryptography went wrong
she's pretty good resource he's also got
a website where you can actually try out
some of these ciphers you can encode and
decode messages and do things like that
another good resource if you're
interested in modern cryptography is
Bruce Schneier site British lies a
well-known with cryptographer I work for
a lot of leading Corp companies on
security and things like that he also
created Blowfish and the B crypt hash
function which hopefully using for your
passwords so if you do feel like
starting messing around creighton your
own algorithms he's got a self-study
course on his website which starts off
showing you how to I with increasing
difficulty of algorithms you can have a
go breaking yourself one of the things
you know in order to become a good
cryptographer you need to get prove that
you can break other algorithms that way
any but anything that you've done you
you know that if you're really good at
breaking out gorillas and you can't
break your algorithm it's pretty good
but if you're just like someone who's
just turned up to me like yeah doesn't
Bend of this thing how can we trust
that's any good well if you were a
proven track record of being outbreak
cryptography and you say it's good you
can probably trust that so if you're
interested in sort of so get into that
side it's course it's pretty good
a final link there is a library called
PHP crypt do not use this in production
absolutely not
but it includes a pure pitch
presentation of quite a lot of
interesting ciphers so you actually have
a look at the code implantation for
these including the historic ones I
think it's got a nickimja in there and a
few others it's quite good once it's up
look at the source code and see how they
they tick underneath but yeah obviously
none of those are suitable for anything
other than sort of like your own
personal interest in in cryptography
right hope everyone sort of learnt
something from this talk and found
interesting my my Twitter handles give
up already I've also got get low I get
hope with a few few projects and things
like that one interesting post on my
blog if anyone's interested I broke an
algorithm that saw influence themselves
blog post is actually showing why why
you shouldn't actually do these things
and finally there is a joined in link if
if you want to rate this talk let me
know
there's any good